so we're gonna say the nerd in me was
really freaking out every time Michael
Keaton had a scene with Gary Oldman I
was like look it's Batman and
Commissioner Gordon in the same scene in
a different movie
[Music]
Robocop 2014 edition this is a new
remake and let's just face it this is
happening everywhere it's like an
epidemic remakes are everywhere reboots
are everywhere we have to live with it
what's Robocop about well if you haven't
seen the original film which by the way
you should pretty good movie it's about
a cop who gets killed in the line of
duty
he gets killed but he's very corrupt
people he then has this opportunity to
become a robotic cop through new
technologies being invented thus we have
Robocop who is now out to fight crime
with a new directive he has new ways of
identifying targets he can access any
camera in the city access any case file
he wants to to be able to identify
someone arrest them immediately and
there's a lot of talk is this legal
should this be politically correct can
we actually live in a system like this
the first Robocop had a lot of satire
and a lot of humor thrown in there this
movie kind of ditches that and goes for
a more political vibe is this right can
the American public deal with it that
type of thing sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't but what I can tell
you is this movie's a lot there and I
thought it was going to be in fact I was
surprised at the level of depth that was
given to certain characters in this
movie they actually tried to flesh out
these characters and make them less
robotic so to speak and that was
something that really surprised me they
actually did take time with the
characters which is good however I think
they took a little too much time because
there are elements of this movie that
dragged weird the first Robocop film he
was immediately like robotic and it was
about him learning to access his
humanity again when he becomes Robocop
in this movie he still has his human
side and it's about him learning to
actually be more like a robot and then
the struggle with the human and the
robotic side and I enjoyed that effort
but at the same time I think it kind of
took away from the movie too because it
really stretched out this elongated
training period just to have him back to
where he was as a robot all of a sudden
and then it just felt like we didn't
really get anywhere we actually we
tracked it a little bit but my biggest
flaw with this movie is the villains
they're like they're horrible they're
just cookie cutter villains there's a
bad guy there
this organization and we don't like him
because he's bad and then the actual
villain eventually services but it was
such a weak betrayal of what this
villain could have been that's not
really a very interesting antagonist so
since these villains were kind of weak
in the movie the action didn't really
feel like it had that much urgency so I
wasn't really all that worried whenever
this guy was in battle because he's so
precise he's so perfect at what he does
that it didn't really feel as if there
was any emotion there and I get it he's
a robot emotion is supposed to be absent
from the scenario but emotion in regards
to what the audience is feeling in these
action scenes would have been better
because I didn't really feel as if I was
invested in some of the action in the
movie or him as a character simply
because the opening was him his actual
human self felt extremely robotic which
isn't really good so I didn't really
feel that invested in Robocop as a
character but his family abbie cornish
as his wife was fantastic in the movie
and I really did care about her and her
son and in that way I started to care
more about the characters gary oldman
was great in the film Michael Keaton was
very good I really liked both of these
actors samuel l.jackson as this news
reporter who gives his thoughts on the
various things and does interviews he
was great in the film he had some very
entertaining scenes and a fantastic
opening scene overall I did have
enjoyment with Robocop and it was better
than I thought it was going to be but
the villains in the film and the sort of
emotionless vibe that I got from a lot
of the action did take away from my
enjoyment but I'm still gonna recommend
checking it out I'm gonna give it a
b-minus it is better than I thought it
was going to be and for that reason I am
impressed so guys we saw the movie
what'd you think of it what do you think
of the original what do you think of the
comparisons let me know and as always
guys thanks so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]